what
are you from queens queens is uh i feel
like queens is one of the more
interesting boroughs in all of new york
cause for sure because it's like
everything's there
yeah it's it's the most diverse county
it's so diverse in the world
is it in the world in the world yep that
shit's crazy
yeah we got a little bit of everything
and and
quite possibly i always like you know
what's the better borough
hip-hop all all time is it
brooklyn is it bronze i gotta ride with
coins i think it's
i personally queens is
we have a certain brand of rappers too
like
i mean [ __ ] nas mob deep
50 tribe run dmc hello
no no he's not from queens norris from
queens no he's from left right now he's
component noriega
cnn yup yeah let's the list goes on man
brooklyn is just
very top-heavy though and we claim cold
so don't forget that that's fair
cole came up and got busy with us so
that's another queen's rapper
you know by way of kind of i think
that's cheating though how he sound like
a queen's rabbit
you listen to cold you sound like you're
from queens he's from fayetteville bro
i'm just saying though but you know he
came up when he was 18 17 that's fair
that's fair
that's fair we claim we claim you know
like half that